لطالما شهدنا العديد من حوادث الطيران فمن
مشاهد ماساويه وغير متوقعه كما حدث مع هذه
الطائره خلال العام الماضي في سان
فرانسيسكو الى اخرى متعمده لاغراض علميه
مثل هذه الطائره قبل عامين وهنا حادث
متعمد اخر اجرته وكاله ناسا واداره
الطيران الفيدراليه قبل عقود مضت وبخلاف
الطائره الماليزيه المفقوده وقعت جميع تلك
الحوادث على اليابسه الامر الذي وفر ادله
كافيه على ما حدث اثناء الرحله
قلت لي ان التحطم على المياه لا يختلف عنه
على
الارض اعتمادا على سرعه وزاويه التصادم
والاثر يمكن ان يكون ذاته بين الماء
والارض واخذنا الخبير في سلامه الطيران
المحقق انتوني بريك هاوس في جوله داخل حقل
حطام طائرات تستخدم لاغراض التدريس في
جامعه امبري والدرس هنا يتمثل في صعوبه
العثور على حطام الطائره الماليزيه حيث
يعتمد ذلك على ما حدث في الثواني الاخيره
من
الرحله في اقل من 45 درجه سنرى قطع
الطائرات
الكبيره نعم في اقل من 45 درجه او نحو ذلك
مع سرعه اعتياديه دعنا نقول ان الهبوط في
تلك الحاله يمكن ان يكون فيه فرصه لبقاء
الطائره سليمه نسبيا اعتمادا على الطريقه
التي ضربت بها الماء بموجب هذا السيناريو
يمكن ان تكون الطائره سارت ببطء بسرعه لا
تتعدى ال 170 ميلا في الساعه خلال
الاصطدام اما في زاويه مسطحه فالنتيجه
يمكن ان تكون مثل ما حدث مع طائره يو بي
اس الامريكيه الصيف الماضي في بيرمنغهام
حيث قتل الطيار ومساعده في حين تحطمت
الطائره الى مئات القطع ولكن مع وجود قطع
كبيره مكن ذلك من التعرف بسهوله على طريقه
انفصالها من الواضح هنا ان الراس اصطدم
اولا بينما يكون تاثير الاصطدام في زاويه
حاده اكثر تدميرا حيث قتل جميع من كان على
متن هذه الطائره الصغيره عندما ضربت
مقدمتها الارض اولا وفي هذا السيناريو
الرحله رقم 370 يمكن ان تكون صارت بسرعه
تتراوح بين 500 و600 ميل في الساعه فالاج
نحه والمحركات يمكن ان تكون انفصلت بينما
بقيت مقصوره الركاب وجسم الطائره متصلان
وهذا الحادث المروع وقع في شانكس فيل قبل
13 عاما في هذه الصناعه نسمي ذلك بحادث
حفره الدخان لان هذا هو ما تراه عند
الوصول الى موقع التحطم ولكن ماذا يحدث لو
كان ذلك على الماء تاثير المياه مثل تاثير
الارض فالمياه لا تنضغط عندما تصطدم بها
فبالتالي يكون لها نفس تاثير
اليابسه وفي حين تكافح فرق البحث للعثور
على حطام الماليزيه بعد التقاط اشارات
سونار من قاع المحيط يقول بريك هاوس ان
الامر يبدو مشجعا حيث سيكون البحث عن حطام
الطائره مشابها لحادث تحطم رحله الخطوط
الفرنسيه في عام 2009 عندما تمكن المحققون
من العثور على بعض حطام
الطائره